envie de changement pour la rentrée
table bureau ou encore voiture la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines a décidé de
vendre aux enchères quelques biens sur
Internet on ne dépose on va dire de
collaborateurs dans différents tailles
160 ou 180 on a des plans de travail
tout seul des plans de travail complet
avec des questions on a du mobilier de
direction donc certaines gammes selon
les années à certains prix comptez par
exemple 600 euros pour ce bureau contre
50 ou 30 euros pour d'autres modèles
parmi les 180 produits proposés 4
véhicules de télévision magnétoscope et
même un four à pizza mise en vente 300
euros tous s'achètent sur internet mais
seront exposés ce samedi 8 septembre à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le public pour
ainsi découvrir le mobilier en grandeur
nature à partir de là septembre ne
constituera la quatrième vague et on
espère la dernière le château de La
Coudre ancien siège de l'agglomération
accueil actuellement le mobilier à
vendre il ouvrira ses portes le 8
septembre pour présenter des équipements
en vente exclusivement sur internet
jusqu'au 16 septembre une fois vidé le
bâtiment devrait être transformé en
résidence pour personnes âgées